[Música]
nuevo día de protestas en Francia contra
la reforma pensional del gobierno de
Manuel majón en la undécima jornada de
manifestaciones la policía se enfrentó
con varias de las personas que estaban
en las calles y los sindicatos
convocaron a otra protesta para la
próxima semana
Israel bombardeo la franja de gaza el
ataque ocurre después de que desde el
Líbano dispararán 34 cohetes contra
territorio israelí y el Primer Ministro
Benjamín prometiera una contundente
respuesta todo esto en medio de las
arremetidas de la policía de Israel en
la mezquita de Alaska
y la Corte Internacional de Justicia
afirmó que la disputa fronteriza entre
Venezuela y Guyana debe continuar sin la
participación de Reino Unido que
gobernaba en este último territorio
durante el siglo 19 eso implica que
ahora empezarán las audiencias para
determinar quién ejerce control sobre
ese equipo un área altamente petrolera
conectaremos con Caracas
bienvenidos Estas son las noticias
internacionales en France 24 y yo soy
María Clara calle iniciamos esta ronda
informativa en Francia donde se vivió la
undécima jornada de protestas para
rechazar la reforma a pensional de
Manuel macún la policía atacó con
bolillos y chorros de agua a los
manifestantes y detuvo a 111 personas
los sindicatos ya convocaron a otro día
de manifestaciones para el próximo
jueves en vísperas de que el consejo
constitucional de su veredicto el 14 de
abril sobre la polémica reforma que
aumenta de 62 a 64 años la edad de
retiro el consejo puede derogar parte o
toda la legislación Juan pupiales nos
cuenta más
es el undécimo capítulo de una novela
que aún no tiene su final a la vista
cientos de miles de franceses marcharon
este jueves día laboral en el país galo
en las calles continúa el malestar por
la aprobación por decreto constitucional
de la controvertida Reforma pensional
del presidente Emmanuel macrón el
gobierno no quiere por ideología abrir
la puerta a otra solución que es la de
repartir la riqueza de manera diferente
y de cobrar impuestos a los más ricos
a lo largo de este jueves se registraron
choques en París nantes en la capital
gala incluso hubo un ataque contra el
que se considera es el restaurante
favorito de presidente macrón mientras
el mandatario completaba un viaje a
China desde su oficina cargaron contra
los sindicatos por las infructuosas
negociaciones desde estas uniones con
las que El Ejecutivo se reunió el
miércoles insisten en mantener el
llamado a tomarse las calles
esta reforma es percibida como brutal e
injusta por los trabajadores y las
trabajadoras y la juventud quien han
entendido que van a tener que trabajar
más tiempo sin que el empresariado ni
los empleadores públicos se sometan a la
contribución
la nueva movilización se fijó para el 13
de abril en la víspera del día marcado
para que el consejo constitucional
decida sobre la aprobación definitiva de
la reforma pensional y la admisibilidad
de un pedido de referendo por parte de
la oposición
[Música]
las tensiones entre israelíes y árabes
siguen en aumento el ejército de Israel
bombardeó la franja de gaza y Poco
después las autoridades afirmaron que se
prendieron las alarmas antiaéreas en el
sur de Israel esto ocurre pocas horas
después de que desde el Líbano
dispararán 34 cohetes ningún grupo se ha
atribuido el ataque pero el Primer
Ministro Benjamín acusó a jamás y
prometió una dura respuesta les contamos
más en el siguiente reporte
durante una reunión de emergencia con la
cúpula militar de su país el Primer
Ministro de israelí Benjamín prometió
responder con contundencia el ataque con
misiles desde el Líbano
en cuanto a la agresión contra nosotros
en otros frentes golpearemos a nuestros
enemigos y pagarán el precio de
cualquier acto de agresión
de los 30 cohetes fueron lanzados desde
el Líbano contra Israel
5 impactaron en tierra hiriendo una
persona y causando daños materiales
Naciones Unidas Francia y Estados Unidos
condenaron el ataque el mayor de este
tipo desde la guerra de 34 días que
Israel libró contra hezbolá en 2006
ciudad de la extrema gravedad de la
situación instamos a la moderación e
instamos a las partes a evitar una mayor
escalada
el Primer Ministro libanese micati
rechazó cualquier operación en su
territorio que sirva para atacar la
estabilidad en Israel el ataque ocurre
un día después de que la policía Israel
irrumpiera violentamente La mezquita de
alaxa en Jerusalén el tercer lugar más
sagrado del islam con el fin de
desalojar a palestinos atrincherados que
respondieron con piedras y fuegos
artificiales este año es la primera vez
desde 1991 que la semana santa judía
coincide tanto con el mes sagrado
musulmán del ramadán como con la Pascua
cristiana
de medio oriente pasamos a América
porque el caso de la disputa fronteriza
entre Venezuela y Guyana continuará
según sentenció la Corte Internacional
de Justicia este tribunal supremo de la
ONU rechazó el alegato que hacía Caracas
de que Reino Unido debería estar
involucrado pues era el país gobernante
sobre Guyana Cuando comenzó el alegato
en el siglo XIX con esta decisión el
tribunal comenzará las audiencias
nuestra corresponsal en Venezuela
Daniela Zambrano tiene los detalles
desde el Palacio de Miraflores la
vicepresidenta delsi Rodríguez
acompañada del canciller y el ministro
de defensa advirtió que Venezuela
evaluará de manera minuciosa esta
sentencia y adoptará las disposiciones
necesarias para la defensa de sus
derechos e integridad territorial dijo
además que el único mecanismo válido
para Venezuela en esta disputa que
mantiene con Guyana por el territorio es
el acuerdo de Ginebra firmado en 1966 la
vicepresidenta dijo que en los próximos
días abrió un pronunciamiento de Nicolás
quien además haría una gran consulta a
nivel nacional de las implicaciones de
esta sentencia denunció también que en
el territorio se estaría explotando los
recursos de manera ilícita tres empresas
por concesiones de Guyana recordemos que
Venezuela y Guyana mantienen la disputa
territorial del exequivo desde el siglo
19 un territorio que abarca unos 160.000
kilómetros cuadrados ricos en petróleo y
otros minerales más temprano en la Corte
Internacional de Justicia anunció que
con 14 votos a favor y uno en contra
rechazaba las objeciones preliminares de
Venezuela que argumentaban que esta
corte no podía conocer del caso sin la
participación de Reino Unido la Corte
Internacional de Justicia sentenció que
sí podía entender Una disputa entre
Guyana y Venezuela por el territorio lo
que significaría un segundo revés para
Venezuela en su intento porque el máximo
tribunal de Naciones Unidas desestima el
caso
el presidente de Chile Gabriel borich
promulgó un paquete de nuevas leyes
sobre seguridad incluida una polémica
que protegerá jurídicamente a los
policías que usan sus armas de fuego en
defensa propia antes de firmar las
normas hizo un minuto de silencio en
honor al carabinero Daniel Palma a quien
mataron en la noche del miércoles
durante un procedimiento es el tercero
que muere en menos de un mes este
contexto hizo que el legislativo y El
Ejecutivo pactaran a probar rápidamente
La Ley naín retamal ese paquete también
incluyó iniciativas para Elevar las
penas de algunos delitos y también para
tipificar la extorsión
y este viernes las elecciones de fútbol
femenino de Francia y Colombia
disputarán un partido amistoso como
parte de la preparación para lo que será
su participación en la copa del mundo
que se celebrará en Australia y en Nueva
Zelanda para la selección francesa el
encuentro cobra mayor relevancia Pues
será el primer partido con el banquillo
tras la salida de la seleccionadora
más en el siguiente reporte de Natalia
Ruiz giraldo
la selección Colombia femenina realizó
su último entrenamiento antes del
amistoso en el que se enfrentará a la
selección francesa aquí en selección
colombiana que esta en plena gira
Europea de Cara a su preparación antes
de este mundial de fútbol que tendrá
lugar en el verano entre Australia y
Nueva Zelanda tuvimos la oportunidad de
hablar con Néstor abadía el director
técnico de Colombia y nos dijo que era
Cuál era la importancia de este partido
para la selección para nosotros es un
reto llamativo es un reto bueno saber
que tenemos este partido con Francia y
más acá en su país ese algo que es
estimulante por lo que es Francia pero
más importante para nosotros es lo que
tenemos y sabemos que debemos hacer para
las francesas también es un partido
importante sobre todo porque será el
primero bajo la batuta de ajonar Después
de varias semanas de crisis y de cambio
por supuesto de entrenador quien dijo en
conferencia de que está seguro de estar
construyendo algo importante pero que su
nivel de exigencia para las jugadoras va
a ser bastante elevado Además de eso
también está la expectativa de lo
público pues ya toda la boletería para
este partido del viernes se agotó Así
que veremos Diez mil novecientas almas
en las graderías de este estadio así
llegamos al final de las noticias pero
sigan con nosotros Porque volvemos en
minutos
[Música]